une enveloppe de 10 7 millions d'euros
pour soutenir la construction de
logements sociaux sur la ville du pecq à
commune et le département signé ce
mercredi 19 décembre une convention en
ce sens la ville va pouvoir accueillir
une trentaine de familles
supplémentaires dans un ancien foyer
étudiant ça a été difficile
ce que vous imaginez que c'est quand
même pas simple quand il a mal cette
propriétaire voilà ça a été assez
compliqué mais c'est quand même
incroyable parce que ce soir on a signé
et en un an on a réussi à boucler ce
projet est la ville du bec a donc
aujourd'hui plus de 24 % de logements
sociaux
donc pour nous c'est vraiment formidable
le pecs n'est pas un cas isolé 19 autres
communes du département sont carencés
pour non-respect de leurs objectifs en
termes de logements sociaux
le département voudrait les aider vous
imaginez donc bien que si les communes
n'arrive pas à suivre
ça devient très vite une contrainte
quasi impossible à réduire et sa des
conséquences très graves pour les
habitants parce qu'il y à des amendes
financières prévues sur le budget de
l'état
tout s'accumule effet que c'est très
défavorable aux libertés communales est
très défavorable à la qualité de vie
dans les communes selon le département
un quart des vies les yvelinoises
doivent atteindre l'objectif des 25 % de
logements sociaux dans les prochaines
années